los ataques continuaron hoy en la región
del Don pass comenzaron muy temprano a
las 4 de la madrugada cuando cuatro
misiles cayeron en la ciudad declamators
donde el equipo de Francia 24 pasaba la
noche estos misiles cayeron en una de
las fábricas más importantes de
maquinaria de la ciudad las autoridades
no permitieron el ingreso pero sí
confirmaron que el daño había sido
extenso luego estos ataques se centraron
específicamente A los alrededores de la
ciudad de bagmut a más de 60 kilómetros
de klamators allí bagmut está muy cerca
de ese frente de batalla de civerage
donde se concentra la mayoría de los
enfrentamientos actualmente y allí se
cruzaba artillería permanentemente y
también pudimos observar como la batería
antimisiles lograba detener algunos de
los proyectiles que venían no solamente
hacia bakumo sino a toda esa región en
la ciudad de constantinoca muy cerca a
bagnut podemos caer artillería
especialmente en el campo que se quemaba
en ese momento y como consecuencia de
esas actuaciones vimos en bastantes
extensiones de tierra como las
maquinarias corrían para recoger esa
cosecha de trigo y no quedar bajo el
fuego como consecuencia de la artillería
que cae en muchos terrenos de esta
región y los ataques de las fuerzas
rusas también se extendieron a de la
ciudad de Nicolás en el mar Negro una
ciudad que es constantemente atacada por
las fuerzas rusas